foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-5692
object class
Euclid
special containment procedures
scp-5692 is currently held in a modified
humanoid containment chamber at site-29
the cell has altered temperature or
atmospheric conditions to accommodate
the subject's physiology these
specifications of which are outlined in
document 569211
scp-5692 is to be fed a concentrated
mixture of amino acids simple sugars and
ionic phosphates every 12 to 15 hours
these specifications for the preparation
of this mixture are outlined in document
5692 13.
Class A amnestics are authorized to be
used on all parties associated with the
containment of
scp-5692-a instances specific methods
for the containment of instances of
scp-5692-a are to be determined on a
case-by-case basis by participating
operatives contained instances of
scp-5692-a are to be held in site-29
with containment conditions appropriate
to their physiological needs these
conditions may be determined through
research of the subject or by using
information provided by the subject
further information regarding each
contained instance of
scp-5692-a can be found on documents
5692 37-109
Research into the biology behavior and
prior activities of scp-5692 as well as
instances of
scp-5692-a are currently being conducted
under the supervision of Dr Verner head
of the Extraterrestrial anomaly division
of psych-29 any concerns or inquiries
regarding the research or containment of
scp-5692 or instances of
scp-5692-a are to be directed to Dr
Verner
description
scp-5692 is a slug-like Sapient organism
of extraterrestrial origin measuring 2.3
meters in length and folded backwards at
the midpoint of its body to allow its
anterior half to be aligned
perpendicular to the ground
scp-5692 possesses a head with a pair of
large red eyes and elongated tube-shaped
mouth part and two clusters of small
pores on either side designed to
facilitate respiration
scp-5692 possesses a pair of stalk-like
organs on either side of its torso each
ending in a round sensitive organ
capable of sprouting a number of
flexible mycelium-like protrusions at
will the protrusions have been confirmed
by scp-5692 to be a means of
reproduction and environmental
manipulation
scp-5692 is a dull orange in color with
dark and light counter shading similar
to many marine animals
scp-5692 was recovered on October 2014
from a small cabin in a forest near
Oregon after several reports of UFO
activity in the region were investigated
by Foundation operatives the incident
was contained without incident and upon
being confronted by operatives
scp-5692 surrendered willingly into
Foundation custody
scp-5692 has been Cooperative with
Foundation staff since its containment
and appears to answer most inquiries
with sincerity
scp-5692 was able to communicate using a
small electronic device embedded
directly in its nervous system at the
point where structure is analogous to a
brain and ocular nerves meet according
to scp-5692 the device is a translator
capable of processing various methods of
visual communication including written
words and the movement of lips and
directly implanting the abstract
Concepts they represent into the brain
of scp-5692
this device is also capable of
converting the thoughts of scp-5692 into
audible words and or holographic
projections of written language using a
speaker or holographic emitter located
directly below the skin between its eyes
using this device
scp-5692 can understand the top 250 most
common spoken and written languages on
Earth as well as several hundred forms
of extraterrestrial communication
scp-5692 claims that due to its
placement removal of this device would
instantly result in its death removal of
this device for further study is not
authorized
scp-5692 is responsible for the
integration of 50 to 55 extraterrestrial
life forms designated instances of
scp-5692-a into Earth societies and
ecosystems between the years of 2001 and
2014 42 of which have been successfully
contained the appearances and reasons
for appearing on Earth vary drastically
among instances of
scp-5692-a all instances of
scp-5692-a are Sapient and have
previously engaged in business
transactions with
scp-5692 the whereabouts and activity of
all contained instances of
scp-5692-a were provided to Foundation
Personnel by
scp-5692 shortly after its initial
containment
addendum 5692 1. the following is an
incomplete list of contained instances
of
scp-5692-a the recovery of all subjects
took place within a few months of the
containment of scp-5692 many instances
of
scp-5692-a disguised themselves using a
complex organic gel accompanied by a
convincing prosthetic skin covering the
composition of the gel varies depending
on the physiology of the subject and is
designed to simulate the musculature of
the subjects assumed identity the gel is
able to respond to neural inputs from
the subject and is controlled as if it
were the subject's own body
all instances of
scp-5692-a observed thus far possess a
translation or communication device
similar to the one observed in
scp-5692 all human identities assumed by
instances of
scp-5692-a are of people that had not
existed prior to the subject's arrival
on Earth and were accomplished by the
forging of relevant documents
instance number
scp-5692 A3
description a reptilian humanoid entity
measuring 1.8 meters in height The
Entity could change its outward
appearance to resemble any human to an
indistinguishable degree reasons for
appearing on Earth are currently under
investigation remains of the subject are
currently held in site-29's biolab
recovery report the subject was found to
be posing as a politics professor at the
University for several years it is
unknown if this is the only identity the
subject assumed while on Earth upon
Discovery by Foundation operatives the
subject injected itself with an unknown
chemical compound that converted its
bodily tissues excluding its skin into a
thick green basic solution resulting in
death in a matter of seconds
additional information provided by
scp-5692
I'm not entirely sure why he came to me
he was more than capable of hiding on
his own and by the sounds of things he
had some pretty powerful friends
instance number
scp-5692 a11
description an organisms superficially
resembling a rodent with hairless white
skin and measuring 0.8 meters in length
the subject possesses five prehensile
tails capable of manipulating its
environment and lacks hind limbs ears
and nostrils the subject was apparently
on Earth to hide from an
extraterrestrial crime organization that
it was formerly affiliated with
recovery report the subject adopted the
false identity of Ricky Bambino bucelli
and engaged in organized criminal
activity in Chicago for a period of
several years the subject was contained
without incident on several occasions
since its initial containment the
subject has offered to exchange
information about its former crime
Affiliates both terrestrial and
extraterrestrial in exchange for Freedom
or special containment privileges
additional information provided by
scp-5692
once a rat always a rat
instance number
scp-5692 A14
description a silicon-based organism
measuring 0.27 meters in length
resembling a translucent graceffalopod
with four Limbs and a cartilaginous
endoskeleton the subject was required to
regularly consume sand to facilitate its
bodily needs according to the subject it
is a refugee of a massive Interstellar
War surrounding the kepler-22 star
system
recovery report the subject used a
highly specialized gel capable of
supporting its metabolism and
maintaining a convincing disguise as a
common house cat the subject posed as a
family pet in a Toronto apartment for
several years before being recovered by
Foundation operatives while attempting
to feed stray cats outside its apartment
complex at night
additional information provided by
scp-5692
all the essentials come free and all you
have to do is sit by the window when
it's sunny honestly sounds like a pretty
good gig except for having to eat the
litter
instance number
scp-5692 a23
description a complex network of
extraterrestrial algae forming
structures analogous to neurons and
synapses the resulting entity is a
Sapient photosynthetic mat at the
water's surface capable of splitting
into separate intelligences and
regrouping multiple of these
intelligences into a single entity one
isolated intelligence occupied a
gel-based disguise of a 60 to 65 year
old Caucasian male the totality of the
subject is currently held in 27 large
containment Vats in the ecological
anomaly section of site-29
recovery report the disguised portion of
the subject was found to live in a small
house at the edge of a swamp in the
Florida Keys locals knew the individual
as a reclusive eccentric known as Bayou
Bill all information surrounding Bayou
bill was successfully removed from the
surrounding area most of the subject was
growing in a 3.4 kilometer radius
surrounding the house causing major
disturbances in the local ecosystem the
Total Recovery of the subject took 24
days due to its sprawling decentralized
nature despite claiming that its purpose
on the planet was to research Aquatic
Life forms it is now believed that the
subject was taking advantage of the
environmental conditions of the swamp
for growth and reproduction the end goal
of which remains uncertain
additional information provided by
scp-5692
what you think it was plotting a
takeover
I doubt it come on now how was I
supposed to know anyway he could fit in
a glass of water when I met him besides
if your planet's weak enough to be
conquered by seagrass maybe that's just
natural selection
instance number
scp-5692 a29
description a 1.3 meter long
superficially mammalian creature
resembling a snake with Shaggy brown fur
and two sets of thermosensitive organs
directly below its eyes the subject's
tail diverged into seven points which
acted as environmental manipulators the
subject also has a litter of 57 purely
aquatic offspring that each measures 7
to 10 centimeters in diameter and
resembles sea urchins with soft flexible
hairs rather than spines the subject
reportedly sought to escape over
population regulations on its home
planet that would require it to
terminate 42 of its offspring
recovery report the subject was
disguised as a 34 year old female
botanist living in a small town along
the Mexico U.S border the subject kept
its Offspring in pet aquariums in the
back of their flower shop upon initial
containment the subject was extremely
hostile but became Cooperative after
accommodations were made to allow the
subject and Offspring to be contained
together
additional information provided by
scp-5692
oh yeah I remember her gave her a
discount I think never let it be said
that I don't have a heart
instance number
scp-5692 a32
description a 1.5 meter tall vaguely
humanoid organism with several avian
features including a toothed beak a blue
Downy feather-like skin covering
designed for thermal regulation and
talon-like hands and feet according to
the subject and
scp-5692 the species to which the
subject belongs has an average lifespan
of 16 years the subject cited tourism as
its reason for appearing on Earth the
remains of the subject are preserved and
held in site-29's biolab recovery report
the subject spent the last two years of
its life posing as a wealthy 70 to 75
year old Turkish man using this disguise
the subject visited numerous sites of
natural and historical significance on
every continent the subject entered
willingly into Foundation custody after
being seized by operatives at Machu
Picchu claiming that it had seen enough
the subject died three weeks after
initial containment
additional information provided by
scp-5692
the man LED
in his spare time faked his death
emigrated on a whim to an underdeveloped
Planet he heard rumors of in a bar one
day
and experienced everything your planet
had to offer all within the span of a
decade we have a saying about the birds
or I come from
they're insane
instance number
scp-5692 a37
description a 2.4 meter tall slender
humanoid entity with thin transparent
skin The Entity lacks muscle fibers and
moves by controlling the movement of
pressurized gas through specialized
organs in its limbs the subject was
native to a low gravity planet and came
to Earth to study the relationship
between trees and fungi in the forests
of North America
recovery report the subject was
outfitted with a gel-based disguise and
a device which could manipulate gravity
in a 10 centimeter radius around its
body the disguise was made to resemble
the North American Cryptid Sasquatch the
subject was found in the Rocky Mountains
of Alberta and was apprehended without
incident
additional information provided by
scp-5692
she was too tall for a human gel and she
wanted to live in the woods for the rest
of her life not bad eh well I thought it
was pretty clever
Research into the location nature and
capabilities of the civilizations that
instances of
scp-5692-a originate from is ongoing
interviews with
scp-5692 and instances of
scp-5692-a have thus far proven useful
in obtaining information however more
direct methods of observation are
currently in development
interview log 5692 3. preface the
following interview took place on
November
2014. in the prior to interviews
scp-5692 revealed the location and
identities of 42 instances of
scp-5692-a
scp-5692 claimed that the total number
of
scp-5692-a instances on Earth was
between 50 and 55 and that it had
forgotten the location and identities of
the remaining instances the purpose of
this interview was to obtain more
information regarding these
circumstances surrounding the presence
of
scp-5692 on Earth
playing log now
hello 5692
I have a few questions regarding your
involvement in the presence of
extraterrestrial organisms on Earth
is that all right yeah I'm sure I can
make time for it excellent
how did you arrive on Earth initially
well Earth belongs to a collection of
planets that for one reason or another
are forbidden by Interstellar law to
contact in your case it appears to be a
non-interference type deal honestly it's
not like anyone is missing out on
anything
I don't find this place nearly as
interesting or endearing as some of my
customers do either way a good place to
hide and as I came to discover make a
profit while I'm at it hide
from what
more appropriate to ask from who an even
more appropriate to ask who are not
hiding from are you a fugitive you make
it sound like I'm dangerous I pulled one
too many fast ones and before I knew it
eight of the 15 largest Government
powers in the Galaxy were on to me many
of which might I add think execution is
an appropriate punishment for stealing
at your Kokomo much less let's call them
dishonest business dealings
earlier you referred to the
extraterrestrials you assisted as
customers
what sort of payment do they provide you
for your services well first off their
ship they give up their ship and
everything on it along with a package of
additional Goods depending on where the
customer came from I'd do my research
ahead of time
what were some of these Goods
stuff that's universally valuable you
know precious metals Black Market
organic materials illegal Technologies
stuff like that that way I can trade
them in for whatever currency made the
most sense when I got back to the Grift
so once they made that deal with you
they had no way of getting off work ah
that was the beauty of it if you are
desperate enough to relocate for the
rest of your life then you're probably
also willing to Shell out an arm leg or
equivalent appendage plus you couldn't
go and tell your friends about your
vacation on Earth after you left last
thing I wanted was to attract unwanted
attention once you're in you are in that
was rule number one what were the other
rules Common Sense stuff you know no
Transmissions of world avoid doctors
cops or anyone wearing a tin foil hat
you can
in exchange they knew I would keep quiet
and they could safely do
well whatever they came here to do
without being harassed
so why did you decide to give up
information about your customers to us
they provided you things of immense
value for your secrecy
well I can't trade in any of those
things for money now and even if I could
what good would it do me in here no they
can live like me now
what's the saying our goose is cooked
they knew the risks when they broke the
interstellar law
although I'm sure if they knew this was
a concealer world that they might have
thought twice a concealer well yeah you
know a world with a big shadowy
organization that hunts down things that
don't make total sense
there's at least half a dozen others you
guys are unique though in what ways
well you make some of the other guys
look sloppy
I lived here for 13 years and I never
once suspected there was such an
organization on this planet well done
I'm usually pretty good at spotting
these sorts of things
most of them also prefer to terminate
dangerous things rather than put them in
a box
I was lucky you had the philosophy you
did otherwise it would have been no
different than being executed for one of
my harmless games
well mostly Among Us any additional
information you can provide about these
organizations
it would be nice to know what our
counterparts are up to
one thing all you guys have in common is
that once you have someone in your
sights they're as good as yours that's
why I surrendered so easily when I saw
you guys showing up to my cabin I wonder
if Keswick knew about you guys
oh that would make it even more
infuriating
well I think that will do for today
we'll have to get you to expand on some
of the points you've laid out here today
at a later date yeah yeah sure I got
nothing better to do
and luck
final notes
this is the third time
scp-5692 brought up a person named
Keswick from what I could gather Keswick
is a person that assisted
scp-5692 in smuggling aliens onto Earth
I'll see what sort of Intel we can
gather on our own before questioning
5692 if the two are still working
together the information provided by
5692 may be intentionally misleading
Dr Verner
interview log 5692 4. preface the
following interview is conducted on
November
2014. in Prior interviews
scp-5692 had briefly alluded to the
existence of an apparently non-anomalous
human collaborator in his mid to late
30s known as Keswick subsequent
interviews with instances of
scp-5692-a have shown that subjects are
unaware of these specific events or
entities involved in their integration
and have only a vague recollection of
the identity of Keswick and
scp-5692 additional investigations were
unsuccessful in uncovering additional
information on Keswick the purpose of
this interview is to obtain more
information on Keswick and his
involvement in the presence of
extraterrestrials on Earth
playing log now
but knowing this place it seems unlikely
so I don't think I'm even going
I know your name but you don't know mine
it shifts the Power Balance little more
in my favor don't you think
sure and may we start the interview now
all right
you like that it's rain man yes I know
very Charming
when did you see rain man because wig
would bring me movies books basically
whatever media I wanted between
customers to keep me busy a lot of Earth
entertainment is pretty weak but it can
be very addictive
I suppose that explains how your speech
is so colloquial
even speaking through a translator
oh well it's not enough to simply speak
a language when you interact with
customers from a whole different world
it pays to give off a certain
familiarity
my charm is a well-known Universal
constant for
very nice but if you don't mind I'd like
to ask you more about this Keswick
individual you've mentioned in previous
interviews all I've been waiting for
this one
all right let's get into it
what precisely was your role when in the
interrogation of extraterrestrials on
Earth
well I was responsible for receiving
Transmissions from customers making the
gel disguises setting up the customers
with the machines they need educating
the customer on Earth's customs and of
course handling the Bonafide treasury
required everything else fell on that
sore casswick
can you tell me more about keswick's
role he was responsible for finding
accommodations
the customer
live on initially forging documents
transporting the customer where they
needed to go stuff like that it always
alter with the memories of the customer
in such a way that they had only a vague
idea
it was safer that way
the customers always have no
recollection of precisely how they got
to where they were or who else was
involved
so it's possible others were involved I
don't see how it could have been
possible any other way but the specifics
were always a mystery he'd always get
anxious and irritable when asked about
his methods I quickly learned to stop
questioning him he was a good partner it
is part for next to nothing in fact he
would lose money on every operation and
to us
strange
can you elaborate please
well you were just asked to take bits of
technology and bio samples from the
stash for a month or two and then return
them in perfect condition
he'd also spent a strange amount of time
with some of the customers before
relocating them where they were or what
they did during that time is anyone's
guess not even they remember that was my
first clue something was up with him
I always knew he was suspicious but I
could never resist having a partner that
worked essentially for free
how did you come to be associated with
Keswick to begin with he found me
believe it or not
he claimed to be the owner of the cabin
I was squatting in but I knew that was a
lie because the place looked like it
didn't
a decade
he was quiet and imposing I thought he
was about to kill me or turn me in but
instead he seems to have some vague idea
of who I was
he told me about a con where he would
handle all of the heavy lifting and I
could be rich when The Manhunt on me was
over
of course I quite literally couldn't
refuse
so this game was his idea as much as I
want to take credit I can
you provide any information about
Keswick that you've learned over your
time working together anything that
would help us locate him
believe me there's nothing I want to do
more than bring this guy in but he was
so secretive
I'm pretty sure Keswick wasn't even his
real name other than the occasional VHS
or comic book drop off we pretty much
never interacted outside of business
when was the last time you heard from
Keswick prior to containment
about a week before but I know he was
responsible for me being here could you
elaborate
my species endures a molting period for
a matter of days every few years in
which we are unresponsive to the world
outside our molting ponds
when I exited my molting State I checked
the hiding spots with all the payments
only defined they were empty all my
other belongings including the ships
were gone and there was residue on the
ground indicating that several ships had
taken off
burn your boys in Black came knocking
within the hour and I knew it was over
very interesting
thank you 56.92 I think we have
everything we need for today
no problem you can repay me by bringing
in that car mode password
I'm sorry Vern please don't pick offense
I swear I become my father when I get
angry
and lock
final note
assuming all this is reliable we're left
with more questions than answers was
anyone else involved if so who and for
what reason what that they need all this
alien technology for regardless of the
answers finding this Keswick individual
should be at top priority
Dr Verner
following this interview Keswick was
designated Person of Interest
17235 attempts to determine his
whereabouts current activities and
potential collaborators are ongoing
okay
I think that about does it for today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to zargaran
except
oh crap guy
Trey Adams
the Morrigan
James Saba
Irish wristwatch
Lost Boy
your local Foundation agent
sagnar
zazapan
worthy fire
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Dean dingus
braided Peach
Rowan O'Brien
cake knock
gremnir
extra moments one two three
and James Wright
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you